avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme c'est
sare tu sais comme ouais
ouais
[Applaudissements] [
Rires] pourrions-
nous réduire à 40 nœuds 4S 40s 4 kns
ouais
prévu
pour
pour voulu
[Musique]
plus [
Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
ok, on passe le temps, ok
Ma
[Musique]
viens
à
droite,
pas
[Musique]
ok, c'est
vrai,
peux-tu essayer de les CL et
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire exactement, peux-tu les appeler et leur demander  ce qu'ils
vont faire
[Rires]
Louis St c'est un hélicoptère Papa Hotel
Oscar L
allez-y oui donc juste curieux de savoir quels
étaient vos plans en ce moment si vous allez
faire du travail ou si vous êtes
juste garé,
pouvez-vous  passe Channel 1 n un n um
désolé c'est le seul
canal Marine que j'ai euh Roger qu'en ce moment
nous sommes arrêtés euh en attendant euh ton euh
tu es à l'heure résolue donc ce sera 8h00
ton heure et nous  je vais commencer et me diriger
vers
Resolute Roger, merci,
d'accord, alors : ils vont recommencer à
avancer vers
Resolute
[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
là-bas le Bo
ouais comme le dernier
sur
[Musique]
pour
petit
mets petit B à gauche peux-tu mettre le P ok
sympa merci
[Musique] [
Musique]
ce
droit
pour
peux-tu je ne
sais pas descendre maintenant on descend sur
le
peux-tu demander leur demander quelque chose euh tu le
comprends ouais nous  on essaie de téléphoner
au capitaine juste après mais peux-tu
quand on revient à 8h00 on va
revenir quand ils commenceront à 8h00
euh exactement ou pas tu ne sais pas euh je
voudrais c'est ce qu'elle  dit qu'il était 8h00 ils
allaient commencer l'heure de début et euh on
revient à 8h00 pour les filmer tu peux
leur demander à notre retour s'ils peuvent
faire un petit rond dans les yeux mais bon
on ne sait jamais
essayez on on  essayez vraiment de pH au
capitaine alors ils savent venir chercher des
amis car il a dit sachez que donc
parce que nous sommes censés qu'il puisse leur expliquer que
nous sommes censés arriver euh 7 vous
expliquez que le problème était si vous pouvez quand
nous commençons 8h00  tu peux faire un petit tour pour
nous ok
ok Louis St Ron Papa Hotel
Oscar
il